salud en directo américa de france 24 ya
está conmigo en el estudio más romeros a
la mar bienvenida feliz martes para ti
vamos a comenzar hablando de la vacuna
novavax como lo adelantábamos en el
sumario contra el commit 19 esta vacuna
ya ha recibido su primera autorización
de emergencia para luchar contra la
pandemia si de hecho el primer país en
aprobar la no ha sido en eeuu no ha sido
ningún país europeo sino que ha sido
indonesia que ha dado en la luz verde a
esta esta vacuna recordemos que la
organización mundial de la salud todavía
está revisando estos datos pero bueno
hablemos de cuáles datos son estos que
sostienen el uso de emergencia de la
vacuna nueva bucks es un estudio de eeuu
realizado en eeuu que concluye que esta
vacuna ofrece un 90 por ciento de
protección contra los casos sintomáticos
de kobe 19 y un 100% de protección
contra los casos graves de competiciones
de hospitalizaciones y muertes son unas
cifras relativamente similares a otras
vacunas que hemos visto como la de
johnson johnson como la de moderna o
fighter pero que podemos esperar que
bajen un poco cuando en vez de
realizarse en una muestra de estudio se
apliquen a la población en general de
aprobar en el resto de lugares del mundo
sería la primera que usa una técnica
basada en una proteína que lo que hace
es enseñar al cuerpo cómo responder
contra el cob y 19 porque contiene una
información del patógeno que nos ayuda a
responder a la infección cuando entra en
contacto con nosotros lo más importante
pero para mí para de esta vacuna es que
es muy fácil de transportar no necesitas
estas cadenas de refrigeración que
necesitan otras vacunas como las de a
rené mensajero y eso es una muy buena
noticia para países con menos
infraestructura sanitaria como por
ejemplo los de américa latina- raúl así
es más rico y 19 que ya pues nos tiene
un poco exhaustos pero seguimos hablando
del coi 19 por supuesto porque a todos
nos afecta la crisis sanitaria sigue
avanzando en rusia que pasa en rusia
marc un país acaba más registrar
víctimas récord mortales por kobe 19
cuáles son las últimas noticias las
últimas cifras de rusia pues la última
cifra no es alentadora ya venimos
hablando de rusia en las últimas semanas
o 9.178 muertes en un solo día es el de
la cifra más alta registrada desde el
inicio de la pandemia en el país los
sistemas hospitalarios empiezan a ésta
saturados sobre todo de personas que no
han sido vacunadas escuchemos uno de los
testimonios que llega de los hospitales
rusos dando un paso quien llegó existe
más droga y el sistema de salud está
empezando a colapsar hay falta de plazas
en los hospitales y por eso mucha gente
debe tratarse en casa
cuando estamos con energías puedo decir
que un día en el hospital de eso más co
murieron 26 personas todas infectadas
con corona virus pero no se registraron
en ninguna estadística
esa preocupación alrededor de la cifra
de muertos no es nueva ni en rusia ni en
el resto del mundo porque todavía existe
un debate alrededor de cómo contabilizar
las muertes de cobos 19 y lugares por
ejemplo rusia que siguen diciendo que
cuando un paciente infectado con kobe 19
muere de alguna otra dolencia que
consideran más más fuerte como por
ejemplo un paro cardiorrespiratorio no
se contabiliza como muerte de kobe 19 y
es por eso que hay conteos
independientes que dicen que las cifras
de muertes en rusia deben ser entre 4
veces más de las que dicen las cifras
oficiales no tenemos nosotros la
respuesta a esto pero es importante
tenerlo en cuenta porque
estábamos preciso hablando de los 5
millones de muertos que se habían
superado en todo el mundo y es muy
probable que esa cifra la superamos
mucho antes por supuesto que sin mar
bueno ahora sí dejemos por ahora el
cohete se dejó de lado para hablar de
otra noticia alarmante pues seguimos con
malas noticias no mal porque se
multiplicaron los casos de sífilis en
eeuu que está pasando no me regañó por
dar malas noticias no las decido yo si
es una noticia pero si bien alarmante
porque los casos difíciles están
aumentando en eeuu en los últimos años
es información de un portal
independiente pro pública conjunto con
la envió a por la radio pública de eeuu
que básicamente concluyen que estos
casos se duplicaron entre 2015 y 2019 en
eeuu pero lo más grave es que se
cuadruplicaron en los casos de sífilis
en bebés 1870 bebés nacieron con sífilis
en 2019 y de ellos murieron
128 recordemos las civiles es una
enfermedad de transmisión sexual
producida por una bacteria pero que
también se puede transmitir de madre a
hijo a través de la placenta eso se
llama sífilis congénita
y lo peor es que todos esos casos son
prevenibles porque si la madre recibe
una tratamiento con penicilina mientras
se está gestando el bebé puede evitar
transmitirlo a su hijo entonces esto nos
habla y así es como lo denuncia este
portal y propublica nos habla de una
cierta negligencia por parte del
gobierno de eeuu que es un país que
tiene recursos suficientes para tratar
este tipo de enfermedades y no lo está
haciendo son muertes que se podrían
evitar pues más gracias por toda la
información